David how are you this morning great Dan
how you doing spectacular I brought up
the story of your wedding ring yesterday
and so were you the first guy in the NFL
to wear your wedding ring while you were
playing and you had to tape uh well you
know I did I actually I would take it
off and put tape place of it but i think
that i saw brad johnson do it um I can
mistake on that I think I saw Brad
Johnson do it I've in the Super Bowl uh
and I obviously that's pretty cool a
little backstory wore it you know just I
mean I get our wives go through the same
things we go through just they don't get
hit you know so it's the same kind of
pressure same kind of strain on the
family and time away so just let me know
we're out there with you know just to
get a little little something back to
life so I think I saw Brad Johnson do it
first I don't take credit for it all
right well that was it that's only
reason why I wanted to have you on a
good day you know it got a really nice
office man you got basketball court
that's something everyone got us fired
too i saw shot that on TV oh they hit
golf clubs i mean this is nice David you
should stop by you know if you ever get
to the east coast you should you should
join as a mentor it's a it's a pretty
cool spot man gotta give it to you um I
we talked about these quarterbacks we
talked about this before the confidence
that you have as a quarterback is is so
important and you go back at 2002 when
you got sacks 76 times I don't know if
you start to see imaginary defenders or
pass rushers like what what does 76
they're not imaginary they're right
there what but what is seventy six sacks
due to your confidence level well I mean
assess when you come out it's uh it's
tough because you know you get you get
punched in the face seventy times after
you know after seventy times and it
doesn't matter who's telling you a dude
just stand-in there it's gonna be fine
they like you know what I don't know if
I trust you I don't know how believe you
so it's not the us confidence in
yourself you lose confidence in the
system he was confidence and not that
you don't like the guys around you but
you're like all right guys you know at
some point I feel like I got to do this
on my own and that's when you get in
trouble as quarterback when you don't
trust the other guys it's not so much
the confidence in yourself but when you
don't trust the system around you or the
guys around
you make place for you then you start to
struggle and then it hurts what you're
doing so that's that's where you get in
a lot of trouble okay but if i gave you
a do-over knowing what you know and you
got paid as the number one pick overall
but let's say you were the 20th pick
overall going to a better team and maybe
not starting right away what would you
what would you have taken take that all
day long first picks overrated now it's
a you go into a bad team I had a
conversation with Troy Aikman might be
my first year second year the Super Bowl
is in Houston he came out for an event
or sitting down he's like hey man you
got to be ready when your teams ready
you know his team was terrible
unfortunately just never we never got
there you know we were behind a ball but
Tony Boselli not getting to play you
know not talked to Charlie's an endless
on the NFL network now with me and we
could talk about this lot but even told
me and he says on areas like I wouldn't
take in you if I if I knew we couldn't
protect you know we take Julius Peppers
you know maybe you go to Carolina they
had a pretty good offensive line they
had they struggled you know couple years
before but it's just one of those deals
you look at Aaron Rodgers Ben
Roethlisberger remember Pittsburgh
Steelers they had a great football team
really good football team we played him
a couple a couple times early on and
everyone around the league was like man
all they need is quarterback they just
the quarterback and go in there be
consistent they got a good online good
defense and then look what happens you
know they go on and rip off a couple
Super Bowl so absolutely man I would
definitely take that but it's you know
you at the same time you know you go to
things and now Derek's and the position
he's in so hopefully learn from the
experiences that I went through and
hopefully that it's it's easier on him
because he saw you know the struggles
that I had and he's like man we got to
do that even me I was like I would do
things different I wouldn't do things
the same way I would there's a certain
level of preparation certain level of
just understanding how to how to play
the game and honestly I didn't find that
until i went to new york in new york
being around you I and his preparation
and Tom Coughlin Tom coffins tremendous
football coach man New York New York's
gonna miss him big-time he's a
tremendous football coach but just
seeing the level of preparation it takes
to play quarterback position just
something that you just don't you just
don't know when you come out of school
so you just gotta you gotta bank on the
people around you that they can kind of
lead you in the right direction and that
leads me to these two top quarterbacks
golfin when's how sure can you be that
they're going to be that good that the
rounds and eagles have gone all-in to
get these two deaths you know it's it's
tough because you know if you don't have
a franchise quarterback you're pretty
much not going to do anything to class
might get in but you're not going to do
anything because it just history just
tells us you look at the quarterback
sitive won the Super Bowl invincible
their their franchise guys their top
tier guys so if you don't have one of
those guys everyone's looking for one so
Philly you know them jumping up and
doing what they're doing they they need
one of those guys you know they gotta
have that if if they need for
quarterbacks in their quarterback room
they're trying to find that guy so you
know you not you're not sure Carson
Wentz Jared Goff even Paxton Lynch those
guys all have the physical ability they
all have the skill set Jared and Paxton
weren't asked to do a whole lot in
college as far as at the line stuff that
you need to know I mean very similar to
what I went through in fresno we didn't
do a lot of you know side adjusts or
blitz protection changes line of
scrimmage you know so that was a huge
learning curve for me I mean that was
one of the hardest things that I had to
learn I'm obviously you getting sacked
76 times those aren't all I offensive
line that was just me not knowing you
know and and not understanding how to
give us our protections stuff that just
it just takes time so I look at what
Carson Wentz was asked to do he was
asked to do more obviously it was in a
smaller school but I think that if we're
talking first pic LA Rams I think
Carson's the guy I think that just
scheme why's he understands he was asked
to do things that at a certain level of
line of scrimmage we're not that Jared
and Paxton these guys can't do it it's
just going to take a little bit more
time but they can they can definitely
play it's going to be a you know it's
the perfect storm you got to have the
right coach you gotta have the right
staff around you to be able to develop
this guy understand what their
limitations are and then work with them
you know but they can all do it it's
just going to be a matter of what you
put around them he stated car in the NFL
network analyst joining a Stan Patrick
show is Johnny Manziel his career over
yeah he's not helping himself I mean
there's they're they're almost to me it
seems like that he he doesn't care one
way or the other and that's the
frustrating part is there's just so much
talent and we've all seen it I mean I
talked about it with these guys at the
know
work and we've all had players that were
so talented and they just blow it they
just wasted i mean fresno state
sometimes in the spring look like we
were about to go in the national
championship you know and then guys
would be an eligible to get kicked off
the team and it's not something new it's
just it's frustrating because the kid
he's obviously talented he was an
exciting player to watch but at some
point you gotta grow up this is
professional football this is in college
and a lot of times unfortunately these
kids are never told anything different
they're just kind of pushed through the
system high school you're the best
player no one said anything to high
school coaches scared to say anything so
in college is the best player college
coaches don't standing Somalis just
being Johnny he's just young kid well at
some point these kids have to grow up I
think that it's on the guys around them
to at the high school level at the
college level that somebody needs to
take you know not some ownership but you
know care about to get enough to say hey
man this isn't this isn't good not just
for football but for your life I mean
we're talking about the kid's life at
this point because he's in he's in
trouble for sure yeah but who's going to
take a chance on somebody will they
always do on town well or they they
think they can change you they will but
you know what he hasn't he had to play
well enough really I mean if it was one
of those things where he's he's going
out there he's planted a Pro Bowl level
and he's just being an idiot is that's
one thing but there's also some
questions on this field to that he
hasn't really answered I mean he kind of
still wants to be that college guy and
then running around making plays not
that's bad but at some point I mean just
look at Russell Wilson he developed into
a pretty good pocket passer you know and
he still has that explosiveness outside
pocket to buy time keep his eyes
downfield and make plays and that's why
he's one of the best game Johnny had
that ability in him he just hasn't you
know he hasn't taken ownership of it so
someone might take a chance on me but
right now he's needed to be out of
football for a while honestly and then
kind of get his life straight then go
back professional football playing
quarterback it's not like playing
defensive end a wide receiver I mean
everybody's looking at you did you the
pulse of the team you're an extension of
the coaching staff so you know it's one
thing to be able to play but X people to
play at that level and get a team to
follow you and believe in you it's all
other thing good to catch up with you
you don't a great job on the NFL network
your hair looks great by the way
that hard part man oh that's the trick
you're killin it yeah this one I've been
yeah I've been going with the hard part
for a long time I got a lot a lot of
crap for when I was younger but now it's
starting to be a thing so without pre
good yeah I David thanks for joining us
we appreciate it you you got it buddy
that's how David Carr the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience